Vatican officials say that Pope Francis
is in good shape that's good news this
morning after a successful abdominal
surgery the pope who is 86 years old was
taken to a hospital in Rome yesterday
after his regular weekly audience Chris
livesay is outside the hospital where
the pope will stay for several days it's
good to get great news in the morning
about the pope Chris good to see you
good morning Gail yes I'm outside of
Pope francis's hospital room where he's
become something of a regular but the
Vatican says he spent a peaceful night
here and he's now alert and in good
conditions now yesterday started off
with the pontiff zipping around Saint
Peter's Square in the pope mobile but it
ended with him in the hospital the
surgeon says there were no complications
as they operated on a painful abdominal
hernia remove scar tissue and implanted
a prosthetic mesh it's an area where
Francis has had multiple surgeries over
the years most recently in 2021 when
doctors removed 13 inches of his large
intestine now the Vatican says he's in
good shape his doctor says that he went
straight back to work from his hospital
bed following the procedure as for the
timing of that procedure it's suspected
it was to get France's healthy enough so
he could travel later this summer in
early August he's going to Portugal and
then at the end of August he's traveling
all the way to Mongolia Tony wow summer
of travel Chris livesay for us in Rome
thank you very much Chris